Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір і ласкаво просимо!
Руді Церне розповість про спорт.
Наші сьогоднішні теми:
Довгострокова допомога:
у літньому інтерв'ю лідерка SPD Ескен сумнівається,
що «боргове гальмо» може бути дотримане 2023 року.
За фронтом: команда ZDF вперше
супроводжувала російську армію
на окупованому Донбасі.
І продовжуємо без пропущених голів:
німецькі футболістки зустрічаються з Австрією
у чвертьфіналі Чемпіонату Європи
після ідеального групового етапу.
Ціни на енергію та продукти харчування високі
і можуть зростати й надалі.
А уряд Німеччини має зрозуміти,
чи підтримуватиме громадян і як саме.
Лідерка SPD Ескен в літньому інтерв'ю ZDF заявила,
що потрібні довгострокові пільги.
Вона припускає, що боргове гальмо
доведеться знову призупинити.
Коаліційний партнер FDP категорично заперечує це.
Бернд Бентін розповість детальніше.
Літнє інтерв'ю в історичних монастирських стінах
і в розпал кризового літа.
Лідер партії SPD у своєму виборчому окрузі
у північному Шварцвальді.
Війна, інфляція, неминучий дефіцит газу.
За словами Ескен, безпрецедентний постійний тиск.
Жоден уряд з 1949 року не мав
такого складного початку,
це не можна нехтувати.
Це дуже, дуже серйозні кризи,
з якими ми маємо справу.
Ескен говорить про додаткові пільги,
передусім для людей з низьким доходом.
Це можна профінансувати за допомогою нових боргів.
Тому 2023 року боргове гальмо не має існувати.
Я думаю,
що нам знову доведеться призупинити боргове гальмо.
І крім того, звичайно,
зараз ми повинні зробити так, щоб забезпечення пільг
стало можливим у довгостроковій перспективі.
І, звичайно, це вимагатиме вагомішого внеску,
дуже високих доходів, дуже високих активів.
Призупинення боргового гальма та підвищення податків.
FDP категорично заперечує обидва варіанти.
Саме тому ця вимога зазнає невдачі, вважає опозиція.
Якщо Саскія Ескен вимагає цього сьогодні,
то це добре, але недостатньо просто вимагати,
потрібно ще й реалізовувати.
Саме на цей критерій їм варто зважати,
соціал-демократам.
Лідер CSU Зедер також виступає сьогодні
з власною пропозицією щодо допомоги.
Він хоче продовжити дію знижок на пальне на всю зиму.
Ескен вважає, що це неправильно.
Знижка на пальне. Також прем'єр-міністр Баварії
сьогодні закликав продовжити термін дії до зими.
Важливо, щоб
знижка на пальне
справді поширювалася на споживачів.
Наразі це не вдалося.
Нам не бракує грошей,
Ескен також нещодавно говорила про це.
Звучить як конфліктний матеріал
для світлофорної коаліції.
В Україні продовжуються напади на Донбас
та на південь країни.
У портовому місті Одеса, за російськими даними,
було знищено склад із західною зброєю.
Ракетний обстріл також вразив
житловий район у Покровську
Донецької області.
За даними влади, є загиблі та поранені.
Рідко коли ми маємо шанс
вести репортажі з іншого боку фронту,
з окупованих територій.
Наш репортер Вінанд Верніке побував там,
з російською армією,
та відповідно зі строгим контролем репортажів.
Протягом чотирьох днів
він супроводжував солдатів на Донбасі
та намагався з'ясувати в кількох містах,
як там живуть люди.
Розбиті дороги, зруйновані мости, нежитлові місця.
Це подорож на територію, за яку
протягом кількох тижнів точилися запеклі бої.
Поїздка організована та контролюється
російськими військовими,
які нині контролюють
частини східної та південної України.
Лисичанськ, зруйноване місто.
Той, хто вижив і залишився,
зараз не має води, електрики та їжі.
Російська влада організовує гуманітарну допомогу.
«Ми разом» - надпис на упаковках.
Посил: майбутнє Донбасу - це Росія.
Хто тут керує, Зеленський чи Путін, мені байдуже.
Просто не можна дозволяти, щоб
ця жахлива ситуація продовжувалася.
Зараз має бути спокійно.
Але тут багато хто не вірить в це.
Є страх щодо майбутнього.
Я боюся, що війна повернеться.
Але найголовніше, що тут панує мир
і що нарешті тихо.
Показано зброю,
якою воювала українська армія,
також системи, надані Заходом.
Своєрідний переможний трофей
та психологічний сигнал для НАТО,
що ніби й ця підтримка не допоможе Україні.
Маріуполь на півдні отримав сумну популярність
через сильні бомбардування.
Росія зараз тут веде будівництво лікарні
та житлового комплексу на 2500 осіб.
Міністерство оборони Росії веде будівництво житла,
після чого його буде передано
владі Донецької Народній Республіки.
Відновлення Донбасу триватиме десятиліття.
Але кінця бойових дій не видно.
Для людей ці часи залишаються небезпечними.
На північному сході Греції
розбився вантажний літак з озброєнням.
Усі восьмеро пасажирів загинули.
Літак «Антонов» української авіакомпанії
прямував із Сербії до Банґладешу
і загорівся вже в повітрі.
Багаторазові вибухи завадили порятунку:
на борту було 11,5 тонн боєприпасів.
Місце аварії було огородженим на великій території.
Хвиля спеки дійде до нас завтра.
Південна Європа вже кілька днів страждає
від екстремальних температур та лісових пожеж.
У Португалії та Греції
пожежі значною мірою під контролем.
Іспанія все ще бореться з 20 пожежами,
а у Франції полум'я знищило понад 10000 га лісу
лише в регіоні Бордо.
Крістоф Дестерель.
Вода, мені потрібна вода.
Вже є? Вмикай!
Більше напору води!
Боротьба триває всю ніч.
Пожежники борються з вогнем
у лісі на південь від Бордо.
Не встигає затихнути одне вогнище,
як чоловіки біжать до наступного.
Це якось вдається.
Вогню не дали перекинутися через дорогу.
Отже, наша місія успішно виконана.
Попри це, 14 000 людей евакуйовано,
понад 10 000 га вигоріло,
південний захід Франції страждає,
а сьогодні тут оголошено
найвищий рівень попередження про спеку.
Тим часом в іспанському регіоні Естремадура,
розташованому неподалік Португалії,
можливо, найгірше вже позаду.
Але гелікоптери все ще щохвилини постачають воду,
щоб скинути її на останні осередки пожежі.
Мешканці залишаються приголомшеними.
Влітку тут насправді зелено і прохолодно,
але зараз дуже жарко,
як і на півдні, в Кордові або Севільї.
Зараз екстремальна спека проникає до Англії
та є темою №1 в новинах.
На карті пронозу погоди майже всі території
виділені червоним, є побоювання про 40°.
Це був би новий рекорд.
Відповідальні особи попереджають:
будьте обережні
та, будь ласка, думайте про інших.
Наприклад, постукайте до сусідів
і запитайте, чи достатньо в них води.
Це особливо важливо для літніх людей та дітей.
Всі лікарні в стані бойової готовності.
Країна озброюється перед дев'ятьма небезпеками
усіма можливими заходами.
Ці працівники теж фарбують доріжки в білий колір.
Що менше тепла в металі, то більша ймовірність,
що нічого не погнеться.
У Німеччині майже 4 мільйони доз
вакцини проти коронавірусу
від «Moderna» мають бути знищені,
оскільки закінчився термін придатності.
За даними МОЗ, їх не можна пожертвувати:
Міжнародний Альянс вакцин заявив,
що в цьому немає потреби.
Загалом міністерство за останні 7 місяців
закупило в різних виробників
майже 134 мільйонів доз вакцини.
А тепер про найшвидших людей у світі.
Кращі спринтери з США виграли золото,
срібло та бронзу з бігу
понад 100 метрів на Чемпіонаті світу
з легкої атлетики в США.
Фред Керлі завоював
довгоочікуване золото за 9,86 секунди.
Типово для США, спочатку сила в небі,
а потім сила в бігу понад 100 метрів.
Чотири американські спринтери у фіналі
та срібний призер Олімпійських ігор
Фред Керлі, на четвертій доріжці,
вже 9,79 у попередніх змаганнях.
Олімпійський чемпіон Джейкобс з Італії
змушений відмовитися через травму.
Коронне досягненя Керлі - золото за 9,86 секунди.
2 і 3 місце також посіли США.
Стрибки у довжину: З 6-ї спроби, з 5 до 1.
Китаєць Ван, 8,36 метра.
Перший азієць на першому місці.
У марафоні рекорд чемпіонату світу:
ефіоп Тола через 2 години, 5 хвилин і 36 секунд.
І через 11,09 секунд Джина Люкенкемпер
виходить до півфіналу Чемпіонату світу,
єдина з німців.
Жіноча збірна Німеччини з футболу завершила
груповий етап чемпіонату Європи з оптимальною
кількістю очок завдяки перемозі проти Фінляндії
з рахунком 3:0.
Тому сьогодні було несподіване охолодження
під час високих температур.
Сьогодні на національного тренера чекав сюрприз.
На відміну від попереднього вечора,
коли гра проти Фінляндії минула гладко.
Не зовсім так зворушливо, як попередні перемоги,
але зі справжніми яскравими моментами. Такими,
як красивий гол Ніколь Аньомі
з Франкфурта, яка вперше вийшла на заміну
та перетворила рахунок на 3:0.
У Австрії також був святковий настрій
після виходу в чвертьфінал проти Німеччини.
При них знають ще з Бундесліги.
Ми знаємо, що це добре підготовлена,
досвідчена команда,
але ми також знаємо при принципи її гри з Бундесліги.
Тому я з нетерпінням чекаю на поєдинок проти Австрії.
Але вони точно не думали про це
під час сьогоднішніх водних ігор.
Бельгієць Єспер Філіпсен виграв
15-й етап Тур де Франс.
У масовому спринті він обійшов
свого земляка Воута ван Арта.
Йонас Вінгегор з Данії зберігає жовту майку,
Зімон Ґешке продовжує гонку в гірській майці.
Ми коротко розповіли про спорт в неділю,
тепер про погоду.
Ми вже згадували, що
найближчими днями буде досить спекотно.
Завтра на півдні буде сонячно,
температура від 27 до 36°.
На півночі подекуди хмарно.
На узбережжях свіжий вітер та 23-27°.
У вівторок температура сягатиме 40°.
У середу на заході очікуються грози.
Крістіан Зіверс вітає вас
у випуску «heute journal» о 9:15.
А ми дякуємо і прощаємось
та чекаємо на вас завтра з новим випуском новин.